d'où venons nous où en sommes nous où
allons nous
ces trois questions que naguère le
général de gaulle aux aides aux
françaises et aux français pour leur
proposer des réponses communes fondées
sur la mémoire et tournée vers l'avenir
nous prend nous les poser à notre tour
aujourd'hui sa ligne g en ruine après
200 jours et 200 nuit de combats
terrifiants
et aujourd'hui honorable et celle que
l'on appelait tristement le fil sans
adresse
est ce encore la volga 2 millions de
sourires et de larmes la vie a triomphé
c'est bien la preuve que pour diriger le
monde
l'intelligence ne suffit pas il faut du
coeur il y faut de la grandeur d'âme
pour conduire les hommes et porter
l'espérance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
suite
[Musique]
soyaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et is very moving place because it is a
place with everyone et célébrer le sacre
face à nîmes bing for freedom for peace